est-ce que le pain que vous étiez
appellent les flics quand les voisins
font trop de bruit
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors on vous présente plus votre
premier coup des classes était en 1985
en pleine famille en Éthiopie pour lever
des fonds vous avez monté un immense
concert de charité qui s'appelle le Live
Aid et qui a marqué toute une génération
pour ce haut fait la reine n'a pas pu
vous nommer sœur car vous êtes irlandais
contrairement à Elton John vous avez été
nommé chevalier de l'Ordre de l'Empire
britannique voilà alors le live aide
c'était il y a 20 ans et en juillet
dernier vous avez remis ça avec le live
eight c'est à dire 10 concerts donnés
dans autant d'endroits différents dans
le dans le monde un million virgule
500000 personnes ont assisté à ces
concerts gratuits à Londres à Versailles
à Tokyo à Philadelphie à Berlin à Rome à
Moscou à Johannesburg et à Barry au
Canada pour écouter Paul McCartney Pink
Floyd reformer exceptionnellement
U2 avec Bono Coldplay Black Eyed Peas
Madonna Alicia Keys Mariah Carey Robbie
Williams 2 de gens en vue ces concerts à
la télévision alors le climax de
ces concerts ça a été cambiran waldu est
apparu souriante vêtue de blanc sur la
scène de hype Park alors c'est une
éthiopienne de 24 ans étudiante en
agronomie qui est une miraculée en fait
parce que c'est en voyant son visage à
l'époque à la télévision que vous aviez
décidé de faire le lived il y a il y a
20 ans c'est ça
j'étais plutôt déprimé à l'époque
je fais partie d'un groupe qui
s'appelait boom tamrax et mon nouvel
album ne se vendait pas bien
alors je suis rentré chez moi un soir il
y avait une petite fille
j'allume la télé je vois son image et je
vois ce scandale
30 millions
de personnes qui meurent de faim dans un
monde où il y a des excédents
alimentaires et ça j'ai trouvé ça
absolument intolérable c'est une
véritable pornographie de la pauvreté
[Musique]
la seule chose que j'ai pu faire c'est
écrire des chansons invité mes amis à se
joindre à moi
il y a 20 ans on ne pouvait que traiter
le symptôme de la pauvreté parce que le
monde était coincé dans la guerre froide
mais aujourd'hui
il y a plus de fluidité politique on
peut s'attaquer aux structures de la
pauvreté et la pauvreté liée à la
politique vous parlez de la situation en
France la pauvreté c'est politique alors
cette fillette à l'agonie était déjà
enveloppée dans son suaire par son père
car sa mère et sa soeur étaient déjà
morte et donc 20 ans après quand vous
avez fait le live eight elle est revenue
elle a dit simplement merci je vous aime
dans sa langue la Marie
un petit peu ridicule qu'on verrait dans
les dans les tabloïdes dans les grandes
journaux je ne sais pas à la télé la
plupart des gens ont vu c'est tout petit
extrait de l'humanité humaine elle avait
que 10 minutes à vivre cette pauvre
fille bien 20 ans plus tard c'est cette
jeune femme élégante très digne en même
temps une intellectuelle effectivement
ingénieur agronome et
c'était le même journal de sol qu'il a
retrouvé dans un village dans le nord de
l'Éthiopie elle l'avait jamais entendu
parler des rockstars de France
d'Angleterre d'ailleurs mais elle avait
entendu parler de Madonna curieusement
mais je crois qu'elle confondait
confondait avec la Vierge Marie enfin
bon toujours est-il que la Madone
Madonna la fait venir sur scène et vous
avez deux femmes comme de caractères qui
étaient là c'est un moment quand même
important
cela étant la réalité d'ailleurs tout ça
c'est que toutes les chansons du monde
ne peuvent attirer l'attention sur un
problème la raison pour laquelle on a
fait la veille c'était justement pour
contraindre les leaders du G8 qui seront
rencontrés en Grande-Bretagne à arriver
à quelque chose enfin faire quelque
chose de concret et ça a marché quand
même ça marchait parce que le Conseil
adverse le concert à versa a été
magnifique tous ces concerts d'ailleurs
et c'est superbe ont permis de faire
doubler l'aide à l'Afrique on a annulé
la dette des pays les plus pauvres
d'Afrique et puis sur le plan humain si
on peut mesurer tout cela en terme
humain vous avez 5 millions de personnes
qui resteront en vie chaque année après
l'an 2010 5 millions d'orphelins qui
seront prises en charge 21 millions de
personnes qui pourront aller à l'école
290 millions de personnes qui seront
libérées du fardeau de la dette vous
aurez un traitement universel du sida et
une réduction de 50% de la mortalité due
au paludisme donc quelquefois la musique
pop peut faire des résultats
bravo
alors tout ça sort en DVD il y a les
concerts il y a le backstage il y a un
truc extraordinaire c'est les
répétitions du Pink Floyd qui est en
train de se reformer ils ont pas joué
ensemble depuis des années vous avez
déclaré j'espère que ce sera la
meilleure vente de DVD de l'histoire il
faut que notre génération soit celle qui
aura éradiquer la pauvreté faisant ça
pour tous ceux qui ne peuvent même pas
ramper
la pauvreté que de reformer les Pink
Floyd croyez moi c'était pas une mince
affaire
c'est comme quatre couples divorcés
qu'on essaie de réunir après 25 ans de
d'animosité de récrimination de
dispute financière
[Musique]
et puis bon si ça aide à mettre la fin
la pauvreté je crois que c'était un vrai
résultat là aussi j'aurais dû être
conseillé matrimonial j'ai raté une
vocation là quand Bono a dit qu'il
voulait commencer par ça je ne papers
vous avez le secrétaire général des
Nations unies qui est fondu qui a fondu
en l'armée burguette sur le plus riche
du monde qui était là tout est nul lui
aussi mais pour moi c'était comme un
choc presque physique parce que j'avais
grandi avec cette chanson et puis tout
d'un coup vous avez toute la promesse du
rock toutes ces idées tous ces rêves qui
se concrétisent et toutes les
possibilités qui deviennent vraiment
possibles donc pour moi c'était c'était
ça ce que j'ai ressenti Zazie vous avez
déclaré que avec le rock n' roll
l'humanitaire peut devenir un plaisir
finalement bah oui c'est bien moi je
pense que c'est ça l'humanité moderne
c'est plutôt moi quand on parle en me
disant
ils sont pauvre donne franchement quand
on parle sur ce ton j'ai pas du tout
envie de donner quoi que ce soit parce
que j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir volé
mon argent non plus par contre partagez
le plaisir nous on n'est pas très doué
pour aller mettre des des injections
dans les bras des enfants qui sont
malades quoi on est doué pour faire de
la musique donc on peut partager ce
plaisir-là ensemble qu'on soit dans un
lit d'hôpital ou star de rock'n'roll
c'est c'est ce que fait la musique de
magnifique et tout le monde c'est ce
qu'il a fait avec Live aide et ensuite
avec
je suis bien d'accord le travail de
l'artiste c'est de faire de l'art de
l'art de qualité c'est possible s'il
fait de l'art de mauvaise qualité il a
échoué et c'est de faire quelque chose
d'autre grâce à son art c'est une autre
affaire alors Bob Gilder pour vous a
reproché de ne pas avoir invité au live
eight assez de noir sur scène le seul
qui était prévu c'était Youssou N'Dour
qui s'est dit choqué dans mon album de
Blur et de Gorillaz
aux crises Blackwell le fondateur
d'Islande sont été aussi choqués vous
vous dites c'est pas une question de
couleur mais de popularité et comme vous
vouliez peser sur les gouvernements vous
avez décidé finalement de prendre les
artistes les plus connus voilà c'est ça
vous dites que finalement en Afrique les
gamins ils écoutent pas des chanteurs
sénégalais ils écoutent fifty cent et
Eminem c'est vrai
parce que j'ai dit c'est qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un événement culturel c'est un
instrument politique c'est-à-dire qu'il
fallait créer un événement d'une telle
importance qu'il devenait politiquement
impossible de nous refuser et si on veut
créer un événement vraiment mondial il
faut utiliser effectivement des groupes
qui se vendent à des centaines de
millions d'exemplaires parce que là on
attire le public alors la critique qu'on
avait fait était peut-être déplacer un
peu bête parce qu'il y avait un concert
à Johannesbourg par exemple où il y
avait Nelson Mandela et des artistes
africains et si vous voulez regarder ce
concert vous pouvez voir le concert
français ou celui de Moscou ou encore
celui du Japon ou d'Afrique en France il
y avait des artistes français en Afrique
des artistes africains en Angleterre des
artisans anglais aux États-Unis des
Américains donc c'est un petit peu bête
de dire une chose alors ceci étant vous
dites que les gens ont une vision très
romantique de l'Afrique une vision trop
politiquement correcte
on se dit toujours que les Africains
sont des squelettes ambulants mais quand
on va l'Afrique bon si on arrive là ils
vont ils vont s'effondrer c'est pas tout
à fait ça quand même mais l'Afrique
c'est certainement le continent le plus
pauvre du monde incroyablement pauvre et
il est qu'à quelques kilomètres quelques
bracelets de l'Europe et chaque jour en
Europe nous versons en subvention au
titre de chaque vache chaque animal
superflu on verse 2 dollars 50 par jour
pour ces animaux par animal en Afrique
c'est un dollar par jour en fait le
calcul
en Europe on donne 2 dollars 50 pour une
vache et pour l'Afrique on donne un
dollar
continuer
c'est sur le plan économique c'est une
distorsion grotes mais également sous le
plan moral parce qu'on est en train de
dire qu'un être humain vaut 1 dollar et
un animal de dollars
et l'Europe dépense environ
850 dollars par animal et nous envers
son 65 scène 65 cents aux êtres les plus
pauvres d'Afrique chaque année c'est une
honte ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
Bob c'est qu'effectivement vous aviez un
groupe punk qui s'appelait les bountom
Ratz et c'est incroyable que vous soyez
devenu cette espèce comme ça de de
prophète de l'aide au plus démunis c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque vous êtes pas du tout
comme maintenant vous affirmez vous êtes
lancé dans la musique pour devenir riche
et célèbre pour vous taper des filles
enfin vous auriez pu devenir finalement
une rock star comme les autres quoi non
moi je trouve ça très bien j'ai eu les
femmes la célébrité pas d'argent par
rapport
petite coupe et tout et en plus
vous étiez punk on va voir ce qui est
devenu le punk aujourd'hui on va faire
une interview punk
est-ce que le pain que vous étiez défend
George Bush aujourd'hui
non
pour ce qui concerne l'Afrique et
uniquement l'Afrique indépendamment du
reste à part du savon pour ce qui est de
l'Afrique c'est très curieux il faut pas
me demander pourquoi mais se trouve que
c'est le président américain le plus
radical que jamais multiplié par 3
lettres l'aide à l'Afrique il a lancé un
programme très programme très complet
contre le sida c'est deux enfants
travaillent dans des cliniques sur le
sida pour le sida en Afrique et son
épouse participe à l'éducation des
femmes africaines est-ce que le pain que
vous y étiez investi tous ces droits
d'auteur dans les obligations à 8 % par
an
parce que je ne comprends rien au
système des actions obligations mais
j'ai une belle maison
est-ce que le pain que vous étiez contre
le piratage et le téléchargement de la
musique sur internet
quand c'est ma musique
est-ce que le pain que vous étiez
accepte les invitations de la reine
d'Angleterre
[Applaudissements]
seulement si le vin est bon
mais généralement on n'aura pas une
bonne nouvelle
son
cholestéroleton que vous étiez une
mutuelle une assurance retraite
complémentaire
[Rires]
je ne sais pas il faudrait poser la
question à mon comptable est-ce que le
pain que vous étiez appel les flics
quand les voisins font trop de bruit
non je prends mon balai je tape au
plafond est-ce que en fait mon voisin
est un policier justement est-ce que le
punk que vous étiez interdit à ses
enfants de fumer
est-ce que le punk que vous étiez
explique aux jeunes que la drogue c'est
pas bien
ce serait difficile à faire parce que
j'ai écrit un livre il y a longtemps ou
je parlais de la drogue et des choses
comme ça alors maintenant il me traite
d'hypocrite si je soulève la question
je suis un parent plus qu'un temps
maintenant est-ce que le pain que vous
étiez rêve toujours d'anarchie dans le
Royaume-Uni c'était disons les Sex
Pistols j'étais un garçon de la
bourgeoisie de Dublin l'anarchie de mon
propre vivant c'est tout ce que je
pourrais gérer est-ce que le pain que
vous y étiez veut un autre verre d'eau
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu